MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA
CURRENTLY STAND ON THE SOCIAL
SPENDING BILL.
SO JOINING US NOW WITH THAT ON
THE TABLE, BERNIE SANDERS,
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
WHERE DO NEGOTIATIONS STAND
RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT WHAT WILL
LIKELY HAPPEN TOMORROW,
ANDERSON -- I CAN'T BE SURE --
IS THAT THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL WILL NOT
SUCCEED.
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK IS THE
RIGHT THING, AND I SUPPORT THE
PROGRESSIVES IN THE HOUSE FOR
DOING THAT.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS WHAT
THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WANTS.
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT.
WHAT 95% OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE WANT ARE TWO
MAJOR PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
AND THAT IS TO REBUILD OUR
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT WHAT IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
TO MY MIND IS TO, FINALLY,
ADDRESS THE LONG-NEGLECTED NEEDS
OF WORKING FAMILIES ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY.
AND TELL THEM THAT CONGRESS IS
LISTENING TO THEIR NEEDS AND NOT
JUST THE BILLIONAIRES AND
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTORS.
AND SECONDLY, DEAL WITH THE
EXISTENTIAL THREAT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
WE HAVE GOT DO THAT.
SO I THINK IF THE LEGISLATION
TOMORROW IS DEFEATED, I THINK IT
WILL OPEN UP THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME SERIOUS DISCUSSION TO GO
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN PASS BOTH
OF THESE VERY IMPORTANT BILLS.
>> SO, JUST EXPLAIN THAT BECAUSE
IT'S CONFUSING I THINK FOR A LOT
OF FOLKS WHO HAPPEN TO FOLLOW
THIS.
YOU ACTUALLY -- YOU SUPPORT THAT
BILL THAT YOU THINK SHOULD GO
DOWN TOMORROW?
>> YEAH.
THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE BIT CRAZY,
THAT'S RIGHT.
I VOTED FOR IT.
I'M A FORMER MAYOR.
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT ROADS AND
BRIDGES AND SEWER SYSTEMS ARE.
WE NEED TO DO IT.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS IF WE PASS
THAT BILL TOMORROW, WE LOSE THE
LEVERAGE THAT WE HAVE HERE.
WITH AT LEAST TWO SENATORS IN
ORDER TO PASS THE MORE IMPORTANT
RECONCILIATION BILL WHICH WILL
DEAL WITH THE CRISIS IN
CHILDCARE.
IT WILL MAKE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TUITION FREE.
IT WILL LOWER THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
IT'LL END THE DISGRACE OF US
BEING THE ONLY MAJOR COUNTRY NOT
TO HAVE PAID FAMILY AND MEDICAL
LEAVE.
AND SOMETHING THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON, IT'LL EXPAND
MEDICARE SO THAT WE WILL FINALLY
COVER THE DENTAL NEEDS OF
SENIORS' HEARING AIDS AND
EYEGLASSES, AMONG OTHER THINGS.
AND ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT, IT
WOULD BE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATION TO DEAL WITH THE
CRISIS OF CLIMATE.
>> SO -- SO JUST PLAYING THIS
OUT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE TWO SENATORS.
I ASSUME YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
MANCHIN AND SINEMA.
UM, WHAT THEN DOES THIS FORCE
THEM TO DO?
IF IT GOES DOWN TOMORROW,
WHAT -- WHAT DOES THAT -- WHAT
DOES THAT TIME BUY YOU?
>> WELL, WHAT IT BUYS US IS BOTH
OF THEM WORK VERY HARD AND I
RESPECT THAT ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
THEY WANT IT PASSED.
I WANT IT PASSED.
BUT WHAT IT SAYS NOW IS WE ARE
JOINED AT THE HIP.
AND AS YOU WILL REMEMBER, AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS WHOLE PROCESS,
WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND SENATOR
SCHUMER AND -- AND
CONGRESSWOMAN -- HOUSE SPEAKER
PELOSI SAID WE'RE GOING FORWARD
IN TANDEM.
BOTH BILLS ARE GOING FORWARD,
TOGETHER.
THAT'S THE WAY THIS PROCESS
STARTED, AND THAT IS WHAT WE
HAVE GOT TO DO.
AND I THINK, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE WILL SUCCEED.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL BE
VERY, VERY HAPPY.
AND I WANT TO MAKE THIS POINT.
SOME PEOPLE SAY, WELL, IT'S A
VERY EXPENSIVE BILL.
THIS BILL, IF I HAVE ANYTHING TO
SAY ABOUT IT, WILL BE 100% PAID
FOR BY ENDING THE TAX BREAKS AND
THE LOOPHOLES THAT THE WEALTHY
AND LARGE CORPORATIONS NOW ARE
ABLE TO ENJOY.
WE'RE GOING TO END THOSE, AND
WE'RE GOING TO LOWER THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS BY HAVING
MEDICARE NEGOTIATE
PRESCRIPTION-DRUG PRICES WITH
THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY.
>> SO, SENATOR MANCHIN, YOU
KNOW, HE IS INSISTING HE'S NOT
CHANGING HIS MIND BEFORE
TOMORROW.
HE PUT OUT THIS STATEMENT WHICH
READS IN PART WHILE I AM HOPEFUL
COMMON GROUND CAN BE FOUND THAT
WOULD RESULT IN HISTORIC
INVESTMENT IN OUR NATION, I
CANNOT AND WILL NOT SUPPORT
TRILLIONS IN SPENDING ON AN
ALL-OR-NOTHING APPROACH.
THERE IS A BETTER WAY AND I
BELIEVE WE CAN FIND IT IF WE ARE
WILLING TO NEGOTIATE IN GOOD
FAITH.
SO HE ALSO SAID TODAY HE COULD
BE OPEN TO A RECONCILIATION BILL
BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
SO ESSENTIALLY, YOU ARE SAYING
IF THIS THING DIES TOMORROW,
YOU'RE, IN A SENSE, KIND OF
CALLING HIS BLUFF.
AND NOW, HE'S REALLY GOT TO
NEGOTIATE BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
HAVE THE -- THE BILL HE WANTS.
>> I WOULDN'T SAY CALLING HIS
BLUFF.
BUT ALSO, AGAIN, I WANT TO
REITERATE WHEN SENATOR MANCHIN
OR ANYONE ELSE TALKS ABOUT THE
SPENDING IN THIS BILL, IT MUST
BE POINTED OUT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE PAID FOR.
THIS IS NOT ADDING TO THE DEBT.
>> ISN'T, THOUGH, I MEAN, YOU
NEED SENATOR MANCHIN TO GET THE
SPENDING PACKAGE PASSED.
ISN'T SOMETHING BETTER THAN
NOTHING?
I MEAN, ISN'T -- IT'S KIND OF A
HIGH-WIRE ACT YOU'RE -- YOU'RE
PLAYING, ISN'T IT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
DEAL, ANDERSON, WITH THE
EXISTENTIAL THREAT OF CLIMATE.
AND THE SCIENTISTS TELL US WE
HAVE A HANDFUL OF YEARS IN ORDER
TO -- IN ORDER TO TRANSFORM OUR
ENERGY SYSTEM AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUEL.
THAT'S A HIGH-WIRE ACT.
I -- I THINK IT IS MORALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE, INCONCEIVABLE
THAT THIS COUNTRY IS NOT LEADING
THE WORLD IN CUTTING CARBON
EMISSIONS, AND TAKING ON THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
AND I SHOULD ALSO ADD, AS PART
OF THIS WHOLE THING, PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE NOW
TAKING ON THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE LOWER
DRUG PRICES.
THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE MEDICARE
EXPANDED.
TAKING ON THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY.
WE'RE TAKING ON THE VERY RICH
AND THEIR LOBBYISTS WHO DON'T
WANT TO PAY MORE IN TAXES.
THIS IS A VERY CONSEQUENTIAL
STRUGGLE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WIN THIS.
>> UM, HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO
SENATOR MANCHIN OR SENATOR
SINEMA PRIVATELY?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT EXACTLY THEY
WANT WHEN IT COMES TO AN ACTUAL
NUMBER ON THE SPENDING PACKAGE?
BECAUSE THEY -- I MEAN,
EVERYBODY -- THEY SEEM TO BE
VERY VAGUE ON THAT.
>> THAT'S -- THAT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU'RE NEGOTIATING, YOU COME
FORWARD.
YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU WANT.
THIS IS WHAT I WANT.
LET'S SEE HOW WE WORK IT OUT.
BUT I THINK IF THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF FRUSTRATION WITH BOTH OF
THOSE SENATORS IN THAT THEY HAVE
NOT COME FORWARD AND SAID, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS WHAT I WANT.
THIS IS WHAT MY CONCERN HAS
BEEN.
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE TALKED IN
VAGUE TERMS BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THE SPECIFICS THAT WE NEED.
>> SO YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW,
SPECIFICALLY, WHAT SINEMA OR
MANCHIN WANT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> SO I MEAN, DO -- JUST LOOKING
AT THIS FROM THE OUTSIDE, I
MEAN, DEMOCRATS HAVE THE SENATE,
THE HOUSE, AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
SOME MIGHT LOOK AT THAT AND SAY,
WOW, THAT SEEMS PRETTY
DYSFUNCTIONAL.
I MEAN, DOES THE PARTY BEAR SOME
RESPONSIBILITY TO -- THAT
THEY -- THAT EVERYBODY HASN'T
BEEN ABLE TO COME TO A
COMPROMISE?
>> WELL, LOOK.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE CONTROL OVER
THE SENATE.
THAT'S CORRECT.
BUT I HOPE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
IT IS A 50-50 SPLIT WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT CASTING THE
DECIDING VOTE.
WE HAVE CONTROL OVER THE HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI HAS A MARGIN OF
THREE OR FOUR VOTES.
SO IT IS VERY, VERY TIGHT.
I THINK MY FRUSTRATION,
ANDERSON, IS NOT NECESSARILY THE
VIEWS OF MR. MANCHIN OR MS.
SINEMA.
IT IS THAT WHEN YOU GOT 48
PEOPLE ON ONE SIDE AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OVERWHELMINGLY
ON THE SAME SIDE, AND ONE OR TWO
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
YOU KNOW, IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE,
I THINK, FOR THOSE COUPLE OF
PEOPLE TO SLOW DOWN PROGRESS.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HEARD.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO, YOU KNOW,
GET CONCESSIONS.
THAT'S WHAT THE PROCESS IS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, ANY MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS, MYSELF,
ANYBODY ELSE, I BELIEVE IN A
MEDICARE FOR ALL, SINGLE-PAYER
PROGRAM.
I THINK THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS DYSFUNCTIONAL.
I COULD GO TO CHUCK SCHUMER
TOMORROW AND SAY I'M NOT VOTING
FOR THAT BILL UNLESS YOU HAVE
MEDICARE FOR ALL BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE CAUCUS WANTS.
THAT WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE.
SO I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER AND DO WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT AND TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT, YES,
THIS GOVERNMENT IS CAPABLE OF
STANDING UP TO POWERFUL SPECIAL
INTERESTS AND REPRESENT
WORKING -- REPRESENT WORKING
FAMILIES.
>> UM, I'M GOING TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
I DON'T REALLY LIKE ASKING
BECAUSE IT'S JUST ABOUT POLITICS
AND NOT ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY,
REALLY MATTERS WHICH IS, AS YOU
SAID, THE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HEALTHCARE FOR PEOPLE.
BUT IF THIS DOESN'T GET DONE,
ARE -- ARE YOU WORRIED, FROM A
POLITICAL STANDPOINT, THAT THAT
HURTS THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
>> THIS WILL GET DONE AND I
THINK IT WILL BE A REAL ASSET.
LOOK.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE, THROUGH THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, BEEN ABLE
TO CUT CHILDHOOD POVERTY IN
HALF -- MORE THAN HALF --
BECAUSE WE ARE PROVIDING A
$300-A-MONTH PAYMENT TO WORKING
PARENTS.
IT WOULD BE UNTHINKABLE TO END
THAT PROGRAM, AND RAISE
CHILDHOOD POVERTY IN AMERICA.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS ENORMOUSLY
POPULAR.
LOWERING THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
DEMANDING THAT THE RICH START
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
TAXES.
FINALLY, CREATING MILLIONS OF
JOBS DEALING WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THESE ARE ENORMOUSLY POPULAR
ISSUES.
REBUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
VERY POPULAR.
SO WE HAVE THE AGENDA THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT, AND WHAT
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT IN
OUR -- WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
SENATORS MANCHIN AND SINEMA.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THERE'S NOT ONE REPUBLICAN
IN THE HOUSE OR SENATE PREPARED
TO STAND UP TO THE GREED OF THE
DRUG COMPANIES, AND LOWER THE
COST OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
NOT ONE REPUBLICAN PREPARED TO
DEAL WITH THE CRISIS OF CLIMATE.
THAT REALLY IS QUITE AMAZING TO
MY MIND.
>> WELL, I MEAN, THE IRONY, OF
COURSE, AND IT'S NOT EVEN
IRONIC, IT'S JUST SAD, IS THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE -- THE PARTIES
HAVE CHANGED AND, THEREFORE,
THEY WERE FINE HAVING THE
FLOODGATES OF SPENDING OPEN
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THEY'RE NOT UNDER A DEMOCRAT.
>> YEAH.
THAT -- THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT WAS OKAY FOR THE REPUBLICANS
TO USE RECONCILIATION TO PROVIDE
SOME $2 TRILLION UNPAID FOR IN
TAX BREAKS FOR THE WEALTHIEST
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT WAS FINE.
BUT WHEN WE ARE PROVIDING DENTAL
CARE AND HEARING AIDS FOR
SENIORS, WHEN WE ARE ADDRESSING
THE CRISIS OF CLIMATE, WHEN WE
ARE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES IN AMERICA DON'T HAVE
TO PAY MORE THAN 7% OF THEIR
INCOME FOR CHILDCARE, WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE INCREASED HOME
HEALTH -- OH, THAT'S TERRIBLE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD IT.
AND BY THE WAY, SOMETHING ELSE.
SOMETHING ELSE.
THE MILITARY BUDGET IS NOW GOING
TO BE SOMEWHERE AROUND $770,
$780 BILLION.
OVER A TEN-YEAR PERIOD, THAT IS
MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT THE
RECONCILIATION BILL WILL BE.
AN